you can kind of generally break down
cardio into four different categories
you've got
low intensity steady state um and so
that's usually you're going to find that
your heart rate is somewhere between 50
to 69 of max heart rate and you can get
into all sorts of discussions about the
best way to determine max heart rate i
suppose they're interesting discussions
if you're into it but there's a bunch of
different equations or you could just
test it you know do a maximal aerobic
test but anyway 50 to 69
you're usually going to call that low
intensity cardio and that's usually
going to be done steady state because
frankly there's not much of a need to
have rest intervals when you're keeping
intensity that low
moderate intensity steady state usually
is going to be around 70 to 84
of maximum heart rate uh theoretically
you could do a steady state bout at a
much higher intensity but it's going to
be a relatively inefficient way to do
exercise because you're going to do one
go
and really tire out and and that's going
to be the end of your workout so usually
with moderate intensity steady-state
exercise
it's going to be more of a prolonged
exercise session so you can really get a
decent volume of work in
now
high intensity interval training usually
you're going to see work bouts that are
at least 85 of max heart rate and you're
going to see
you know kind of switching back and
forth between work intervals which are
the high intensity intervals and then
rest intervals which either involve low
intensity exercise or just passive rest
right so uh you you might do a sprint on
a bicycle and and as your work interval
and then during the rest period just
kind of pedal uh very lightly and just
kind of recover or you might take your
feet off the pedals all together it's
kind of up to your preference uh
a cautionary note it can be very jarring
to do super high intense sprints with
passive rest periods that are short
sometimes it's very nice to have some
active recovery to kind of get some of
those metabolites circulating
so sometimes people assume that the uh
the passive rest rather than the low
activity rest is gonna be easier uh
sometimes it can be very nauseating if
you're doing really intense intervals
yeah um now that brings me to the final
one which is sprint interval training
and this is the
the kind of sub type of high intensity
interval training that a lot of people
think is the only type of high intensity
interval training this is where you are
doing maximal intensity
work intervals so the work interval will
be a sprint at the highest attainable
intensity
and then you're going to have low
intensity periods as well with active or
passive recovery so sprint interval
training is a lot like back in the day
when bodybuilders like
2012 2013 got really into modified wind
gates as a
cardio modality
and what they would do
is like a 15 or a 30 second sprint on
the bike
and then you know a minute or 90 seconds
or two minutes of rest and just kind of
repeat through these extremely high
intensity maximal intensity sprints on
the bike so that is sprint interval
training which could be viewed as a sub
type of high intensity interval training
but what's really interesting is a lot
of the common hit protocols in the
literature they actually involve four
minute workouts which a lot of people i
think would assume doesn't even meet the
criteria
for high-intensity interval training and
it doesn't just meet the criteria it's
one of the most common protocols you see
in the literature so a really common
protocol is four minutes of work you
know aiming to get above 85 percent of
max heart rate and then four minutes of
uh you know either active or passive
rest usually it's going to be active
rest when you have a four minute uh
or you know it's usually three or four
minutes for the rest interval so usually
people will do four rounds of that so
it'll be four four minute work intervals
and then between those you have three or
four minutes of active rest but there
are also a variety of different
protocols that involve uh one minute
work intervals two minute three minute
four minute and some as short as you
know 30 seconds and you'll see sprint
interval uh training where you see
really really rapid sprints we're
talking six 10 15 seconds long
of just super high intensity effort so
the span of what you could generally
call either
sprint interval trend in interval
training or high intensity interval
training we're talking about sprints
from uh you know six seconds long up to
work intervals that are four minutes
long um and usually uh you know
generally speaking if i'm doing a hit or
a sit workout i try to make the total
duration of the session somewhere
between 15 and 25 minutes if you're
doing that and you've got a sensible
work to wet to rest ratio you know
between your two intervals that's
probably going to put you in a spot
where you're able to get enough
you know total work in enough total
volume to feel like you got a nice
session but you don't want to go
overboard with high intensity interval
training so for me personally uh you
know if i'm doing high intensity
interval training i try to do 15 to 25
total minutes and i try to keep my work
to rest ratio
somewhere around one to one so my my
favorite protocol by far
is one minute of very high intensity one
minute of uh active rest and i'll do 10
rounds of that so it ends up being about
19 20 minutes that's kind of right in
the sweet spot one to one ratio work to
rest if i'm doing sprint interval
training again i try to keep it to 15 to
25 minutes but usually because it is
maximal intensity you see that the work
to rest ratio actually goes down
so instead of being one part work and
one part rest usually it's one to three
or even one to eight when you start to
see really short sprints um but yeah so
somewhere in that ballpark of one to
three to
one to eight for your work to rest ratio
of course all of those sprints whether
it's going to be six seconds or 15 or 30
seconds usually that's kind of the range
you don't see a lot of uh sprint
interval training with uh durations that
are too high above 30 seconds maybe a
minute but that's pretty much where it
where it kind of caps
uh but yeah so you want to make sure
that you're you're getting um a proper
work to rest ratio keeping your total
duration i would start out in the 15 to
25 minute range and there are a lot of
different ways to incorporate uh you
know high intensity interval training
even if you don't like the super intense
sprint type workouts